hello
in this video we are going to talk about
lipid rafts
lipid wraps are functional membrane
microdomains
these regions are characterized by
highly ordered and highly packed lipid
molecules lipid rafts are slightly
thicker than the nearby membrane
counterparts
the lipid wraps contain high level of
sphingolipins
and cholesterol
cholesterol
act like dynamic glue which hold this
domain together
now let's talk about how one can
identify lipid raft in the membrane
so lipid draft are resistant
to detergents like triton x-100
if we add these kind of non-ionic
detergents membrane would be dissolved
but lipid draft is resistant to this
kind of detergent and it would remain
and that is one of the way by which you
can extract lipid rafts
lipid draft serve as organizing center
for assembly of several signaling
receptors so from a cell signaling point
of view lipid draft is really important
now lipid draft clusters several cell
signaling receptors signaling molecules
which would enhance the chance
of these effectors to come closer and
transduce signal inside
now let's get
a better sense of lipid raft proteins
there are three categories of proteins
named as true resident protein signaling
receptors and proteins and cytoskeletal
elements
so the true resident proteins include
gpi anchored protein
cavioline
flutiline
the signaling receptor proteins might
include
g protein coupled receptor it might also
involve receptor tyrosine kinase
actually many receptors are associated
with lipid raft and they form a receptor
cluster complex actually
then there are other cytoskeletal
proteins such as
acne and myosin can be associated with
it there could be adhesion molecules
like cadherins into greens which can be
found in the lipid draft other than that
glycoproteins and several
glycations can also be found in the
lipid raft
now there are two subtypes of lipid
draft one in is known as type one and
another is type two lipid raft type one
lipid raft is small flush shape uh
invagination that is highly enriched in
cavulin and or often is involved in
caviolen mediated endocytosis
and type 2 lipid graft which is also
known as the linear repeat raft
is mostly found in neurons and are
highly enriched in the protein floating
lipid rafts are pretty much dynamic in
nature
they can fuse with each other and
forming a bigger lipid raft and a
big lipid raft can split from each other
and forming smaller lipid drafts
so overall they are pretty dynamic
concentration of lipid raft would also
determine the membrane fluidity if you
want to learn more about the techniques
by which you can learn membrane fluidity
you can click on the i button
anyway let's talk about the functional
aspect of lipid draft
we'll take one example
lipid raft play very important role in
the events of b cell activation
all the b cell receptors which are
membrane bound antibodies are getting
associated in these lipid rafts
and this lipid raft holds several
kinases such as ling
psych all of these together in this
signaling unit
and this allows the
signaling to be activated in a stronger
fashion
in case you want to learn more about b
cell activation in details you can click
on the i button
so this is all about lipid wraps it's a
brief video all the notes are associated
with this lipid craft can be found in my
facebook page you can click on the link
which is provided in the description as
usual don't forget to like share and
subscribe
you can support my channel in
patreon a link is provided in the i but
provided in description as well my
courses are present in an academy using
my code ep 10 you will get a 10 discount
i am present in almost all social media
by this particular name all the social
media links are provided in description
as well see you in next video